con una tasa de infección de casi el
doble del promedio nacional la región
alrededor de la ciudad de cali con costa
al canal de la mancha recibe el golpe de
nuevas restricciones al igual que la
vecina dunkerque o la costa azul 1,4
millones de residentes estarán
confinados en el norte los siguientes
cuatro fines de semana no es normal
estamos en el norte en búnker que tienen
dos fines de semana nosotros más hay
kilómetros de espacio podemos pasear sin
rozar nos unos a otros no hay el gentío
de parís como se ve en el canal san
martín abro sábados y domingos esta es
la fiesta de las abuelas y esperaba
poder trabajar mucho a excepción de los
supermercados los centros comerciales de
más de 5.000 metros cuadrados quedan
cerrados hoy francia tiene 23
departamentos en alto riesgo luego de
que el primer ministro incluyera a en
off y altos alpes en la lista
allí los puntos de encuentro pueden ser
prohibidos y de hecho ciudades como
parís y burdeos no permitirán consumir
alcohol en exterior en los centros
urbanos de este modo con confinamientos
cortos y variables según región francia
intenta evitar un bloqueo general a la
vez que intensifica su vacunación
y si me me no tendría un sábado
a mediados de mayo habremos vacunado a
cerca de 20 millones de personas es
decir a casi todas las personas de 50
años o más que deseen vacunarse y para
el verano habremos recibido dosis
suficientes para 30 millones de personas
dos tercios de los mayores de 18 años de
la publicación en marzo los
farmacéuticos ya podrán suministrar
dosis para entonces el gobierno ha
confirmado que recibirá el triple de
dosis ergo más de 20 millones de vacunas